alors est-ce que c'est pas là une petite
population de je sais plus quoi faire
on retrouve ces terribles va peut-être
venir on your boots et squeeze hockey le
premier jeu s'appelle el pais gagnent
c'est un jeu dans lequel on vient vivre
un terrible accident et on ne peut plus
que bouger la main on ne peut plus
parler plus rien faire d'autre que
bouger une seule main on va devoir
communiquer avec un mec qui avait parlé
dans notre chambre
evra lui répondent et du coup regarder
la touche pas le petit doigt nous dit
que c'est le twilight c'était pire
expliqué ce monde bien sûr comme la
brearley school te réveiller on
s'inquiétait pour toi du moins tout tu
as eu un accident mais ça va maintenant
ok c'est dur pour toi dans ton est
presque tout ton corps est cassé bah
c'est chiant comment tu te sens je
m'emballe mec ce jeu chiant
voilà je l'année c'est un gars que je
m'en bats les couilles comme ça là je
quoi ça va soulager pas perso blanc qui
fait que ça va souffler on passa sa
catch up keynes voilà c'est un petit jeu
où le but c'est de cette choper sa
copine comme ça au cinéma pour lui
montrer que tu lèves et que tu me
finalement introduire en elle voilà
prince charmant non moi je suis pas mort
state 3-2 jeu massimo fermé il ya pas un
tuto un truc non c'est l'inversé le jeu
ça commence direct la grâce à ses
membres et je le contrôlait quoi avec
comme ça ok et je vais introduire
derrière ça c'est vrai que les premiers
rapports tu sais qu'il fallait pour quoi
je parle
ah merde allez contrôler c'est un peu
aléatoire enquête c'est vrai que les
premières fois où si tu veux te dire
avant d'écoper du coup été un peu moins
de grosses jette genre faut pas qu'elle
tôt avant que tu as ta main de 180
degrés [ __ ] mais c'est dur il faut
calculer cd matin allez on y va en
bosnie qui lui elle n'a rien vu elle est
concentrée dans le film
elle passe sur les atouts de brad pitt
c'est bon c'est bon là oui bravo
monsieur grenouille à elle rougit elle
est contente
alors si tu avais pris la main dans le
sac avant de tâter de son épaule l'a
giflée à tour et peut-être mise
bonjour faire attention la sni qui
technique scratch that each à l'eau du
bain on va y arriver on s'accélère au
sac lherm c'est la même scène mais ça va
beaucoup plus vite c'est ce à quoi il
nous l avait la jambe elle est passée en
dessous quoi attend ian hardacre lyall
d'armagh dans le fournil pu permettre à
noter que c'est qu'ils sont merde faut
passer sous sa jambe je pense c'est ça
mais ouais ça n'a aucun [ __ ] de sens
mais je dois aller au hockey sa partie
pour m c'est quoi j'ai fait un grand
coup avec son bon ok on y va franchement
ce en dessous
oui oh d ela faut que j'ai raté ma
manucure ou bien le visage la déception
de cette femme qui pensaient que
j'allais lui prendre le bras comme ça il
lui demande est sorti avec moi et
maintenant je vais juste me gratter les
veufs hockey impressum fois plus les
mamans rose et drôle sa maman et elle
est au milieu
oui what the fuck
c'est quoi cette afro ailes des oiseaux
de nom d'accords de la marge simpson
on devrait les berges des pierres dans
sap s'est dégagée ce qu'ils veulent je
veux juste les toiles des sculptures
revient au aux jeunes étoiles j'ai
impressionne maman on va rien dire ou
variantes et j'aurais dû perdre sans
forme smara [ __ ] mais ta mère elle
s'est pas directement
oui j'ai eu chaud mais l'étoile au
passage et attention j'appelle à tous
ses pôles de sa fille sous laquelle son
groupe
alors si votre mère va se mettre entre
vous et votre copie de votre copain
appelé mal stb tout de suite ça vadim au
teint hâlé profitons du film ma fille
amusons-nous soient pas des gaffes dp
[Musique]
tonte taille autant que se dire
longuement non it's not voilà think au
nom et wallace et qui toujours ça
est ce qu'on doit ça expliquez moi
c'était le but mais là je te crève l'aï
battu ok tu reagan bon ok je fais
sérieux bien ça c'est quand tu viens de
fermer les yeux comme ça que tu tentes à
londres pour la première fois ta vie
c'est pas le moment le plus stressant du
monde mon gars au jeu dans le pays que
j'aime pas m'exprimer gains le baiser
n'en sera que meilleur oh là là avec
j'ai fait le baiser ben c'est ça qu'on
veut [ __ ] c'est des gens comme ça là
il était cool ce petit jeu mignon comme
saab ont joué en deuxième enfin là bas
c'était un troisième mais du coup ça
devient deuxième les amis on a une
mission comme un peu moins proche de la
caméra dans ce jeu nous allons était un
mec bourré qui allaient pistolet a tiré
dans des bouteilles sans que le ricochet
de la ballue revienne dessus
1 finalement on va aider une personne
qui a besoin d'assistance verts on
dirait un mix m1 dédicaces donc le 8
sept aps été les bouteilles bleu sang
voilà donc la balle noms reviennent
dessus messages venus d'iran qu'ils sont
pas les couilles et comment je peux
recommencer très très vite sans attendre
dix ans au maire de merde j'ai vraiment
attendre autant de temps entre chaque
mort pour de vrai à temps mais je suis
le pire des gourous
j'adore le challenge sauf le wait see my
phone challenge mais c'est parti
ok j'en ai eu la deuxième au nul mais
quelle mouche de merde opus the man who
to qui me fait mal j'en ai marre de
boutoir c'est un truc de malade comme ça
comme ça et
et oui autant
en fait il vise mais rien il est bourré
d'octobre est il trop me mouiller je
peux pas trop vite et en fait aux
[ __ ] je vis bien là je me concentre
ah oui mais là je peux pas puisqu'à du
faudrait que je l'envoie du coup ici
tout ça rebondisse non ici opte ahmedou
haut
non comment je fais pour avoir celle qui
emballe à make up mais c'est impossible
tu as un vêtement masculin aux jeux mais
l'arrivée je m'en bats les roms est
arrivé mon gars je ne vit plus que pour
ça ben ouais ouais
le label d'or c'est autour d'elle et ça
l'a pas eue mais allez allez allez allez
allez allez
bombay steckly personnes 'cela va y
avait facilement sion mais sinon je vois
pas si compliqué hop hop hop ya un peu
du lot il ya un peu du lot ou ailleurs
mais rien non rien à locquénolé hockey
news kendrick merde ça va ce fait exprès
vous en faites pas hop hop hop null null
les bébés des planches de bois devant
les bouteilles [ __ ] mais côté bout et
tu veux tirer avec une arme à feu sur
des bouteilles thulé cache pas quoi
aurait sacrément con et cette musique là
tu aimes ça ok mais clint eastwood
besoin de mon mari sait
[Musique]
allez mettez les pieds dedans faites pas
chier et ben voila si clint eastwood
mesfin cette vidéo j'espère que vous a
plu c'est qu'elle n'hésite pas à tirer
sur le pouce bleus comme ça moi c'était
bien sympa il y avait du jeu très
sympathique aujourd'hui hormis le
premier qu'on a fait merci à dieu ce
sont deux prochaines vidéos portez vous
bien tu as tout le monde
l'api passe
[Musique]